can the brand new pixel 7 Pro measure up
to the iPhone 14 pro Max well that's
exactly what we're going to answer in
this video because we just compared it
to the 14 plus for the same 900 price
tag and it absolutely destroyed it in so
many different ways only a couple of
things it didn't beat it in and the
iPhone is now 200 more expensive than
the pixel so can this measure up let's
find out by comparing everything
including the designs the displays the
performance the speakers and more now
starting off with the design I do like
this unibrow style camera bump it looks
really clean kind of like a cyclops now
in terms of the actual comfort in the
hand the pixel kind of has like these
boxy Corners so it's not as comfortable
against your palm but the iPhone has
these flat sides so it's a little bit
more grippy but not as comfortable now
in terms of the actual weight the iPhone
is quite a bit heavier of course because
it has a stainless steel frame compared
to the pixel which is aluminum but they
did polish it so it looks really nice
almost like the stainless steel now one
thing that some people might prefer is
that on the pixel the buttons are all on
one side right here on the right the
left side is completely clean compared
to the iPhone which has buttons on both
of the sides including that little mute
switch now another difference on the
side is that the pixel actually has a
SIM tray yes the 14 pro no longer gets
it which makes doing 5G tests very
annoying because it's such a pain to
switch esim from phone to phone however
the pixel does have a slower modem so
the iPhone should have faster 5G speeds
now even though the pixer is lighter
than the iPhone it's surprising that
it's actually a little bit thicker
however the iPhone 14 pro Max's camera
bump is absolutely huge it's massive
it's way thicker than the one on the
pixel now in terms of the actual camera
quality we just compared the pixel 7 Pro
to the iPhone 14 plus and that was a
very interesting result now we're going
to do the same test with the iPhone 14
pro Max and see the difference is
because the cameras are pretty similar
but there are some things that are
different like the 48 megapixel main
sensor that is going to be a lot better
for this phone so definitely subscribe
right now so you don't miss that video
now by far the biggest downside of the
iPhone 14 pro Max is that it still has a
lightning Port not only that but it's
lightning 2.0 which is super slow
compared to USBC on the pixel it sucks
we didn't get it this year it seems like
we're gonna have to wait another year
and now let's go ahead and test out the
speakers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow that was a huge difference the pixel
kind of sounded Bland like most of it
was mids and highs almost like
completely lacking base compared to the
iPhone which reproduced those deep bass
notes and it had some punch and
including being overall more clear and
with sharp highs as well so very
impressed by the iPhone and now let's
move on to the display quality and as
you can see I have the always on
displays open right here and one major
difference you're going to notice is
that the pixel has the battery life
which is nice which you can add with
widgets on the iPhone if you really want
to but the iPhone retains the wallpaper
in the back as you can see which you
cannot do on the pixel so that's a nice
addition for iPhone fans however I do
like that the pixel 7 Pro on the always
on display shows the fingerprint logo so
you could just log in just like that but
on the iPhone it has face ID which I
prefer bam instant login now the biggest
difference you'll probably notice right
here on the display is the hole punch
cutout which on the pixel is Tiny it
doesn't really mess with the display
quality however on the iPhone look how
big that pill shaped cutout is it uses
quite a bit of the display not only that
but if you look closely you'll see that
the bezels on the sides of the pixel
display are quite a bit thinner almost
all the way around actually on the
bottom the iPhone's a little bit thinner
as far as the actual maximum brightness
of the phones if you set it to the
highest manually the iPhone is quite a
bit brighter not only that if you turn
on automatic brightness and go outside
the iPhone is once again brighter now
one of the really unique selling points
of the 14 pro and pro Max is of course
the dynamic Island which you can
actually pop up information like the
music app which you can see the album
art and little waveforms you can tap and
hold to give you the information and
Skip between the song and you can simply
just tap on the island to bring you to
the music app without having to go
through the app switcher and find it
there in terms of actual display quality
the pixel comes default with 1080p but
you can turn it up to 1440 which is
going to be using some more battery life
so keep that in mind and that basically
makes it sharper than the iPhone's
display and speaking of the actual
battery life the pixel 7 Pro has a
larger battery however in the battery
life tests that are on the internet
right now the iPhone still beats it out
because of the crazy good software
optimization and that actually includes
the 120 hertz Pro motion technology
which not only runs up to 120 hertz for
super smooth refresh rate just like on
the pixel 7 Pro but it can actually go
down to as low as 24 Hertz when watching
movies or videos and all the way down to
one Hertz with the always on display
saving the most amount of battery life
possible and now comparing the HDR
quality it right away looks like the
iPhone is not only brighter but it seems
like the colors are actually popping up
nicer on the display better color
reproduction much brighter highlights as
you can see and even in dark spot like
this the Shadows look nice and crisp the
quality is just much better on the
iPhone for HDR content now with that out
of the way let's go ahead and move over
to the performance side we're gonna
start off with geekbench 5 of course the
new iPhone 14 pro Max comes with the new
a16 bionic chip very powerful compared
to the pixel 7 Pro which has the new
tensor G2 now the main difference here
is that the pixel has 12 gigs of RAM two
times more than the iPhone's 6 gigs
which is a nice inclusion even at the
base price that's impressive so let's go
ahead and run the CPU Benchmark alright
so the iPhone finished first we have a
score of 1881 for single core and holy
moly look at the pixel man they have a
lot of catching up to do only a thousand
and fifty three points that means the 14
pro Max is 79 faster in terms of single
core that's going to help you for
everything from opening your apps using
basic apps web browsing snappiness
everything depends on that single core
score and as for the multi-core it's
also 69 faster so everything you're
doing between editing or anything that
takes a lot of multi-core computational
power even gaming actually uses some of
the CPU which geeker one points it out
in a recent video great video by the way
that's all going to be helped buy
multi-core and the iPhone just destroys
the pixel in terms of all these
performance metrics you know what let's
go ahead and run the speedometer 2.0 web
browsing test to see just how much
faster the iPhone is going to be for
snappiness while web browsing oh my
goodness 385 on the iPhone man the pixel
still has halfway to go ah no way only
105 on the pixel 7 Pro that means the
iPhone is 3.6 times faster and snappier
for web browsing that just blows my mind
I cannot believe it is that much faster
this difference alone might make people
just want to go for the iPhone with a
faster chip because you're web browsing
using apps that's all going to get
impacted alright you know what let's
give the pixel another chance let's run
geekbench 5's compute test which is
going to factor a lot of different
things in different tests it might even
Factor the benefits of the 10 sir core
from Google so let's run this one and
what in the world it just keeps getting
worse we only have
4425 on the pixel 7 Pro compared to 15
300 on the 14 pro Max that's around
three and a half times faster or higher
score I'm starting to think this new
tensor G2 is just marketing it's just
not impressive in terms of these numbers
let's go ahead and do a gaming test this
right here is 3D Mark's Wildlife extreme
in unlimited mode which basically does
it off screen so the resolution doesn't
impacted let's go ahead and run this
test now I do want to mention yes of
course the iPhone is two hundred dollars
more expensive than the pixel 7 Pro
however if you care about performance at
all the iPhone has just been killing it
so far so let's see how this gaming test
does and there you go we have our scores
we got 17.6 FPS on the iPhone and 10 0.6
on the pixel that is 60
percent faster on the iPhone now that is
a much better Improvement for the pixel
so the iPhone's not killing it that bad
but still 66 percent is a lot for
graphics and I think some people
actually tested Genji and impact on
Twitter posted some results showing that
the iPhone just dominates it in terms of
FPS and now before I answer the original
question of if the pixel 7 Pro can
measure up to the 14 pro Max the pixel
does have some new fancy features
including a brand new de blurring tool
which can actually take your blurry
photos and sharpen them it can also
automatically remove noise from your
background and a couple of other cool
features as well now I did mention the
cameras a little bit in the beginning
but I do want to highlight a couple of
differences because once again the pixel
7 Pro destroyed the iPhone 14 plus and a
big reason for that is the new telephoto
camera which is now 5x Optical and not
only that but it's 48mp megapixels which
makes a huge difference and I wish we
had that on the iPhone 14 pro Max it's
still only 12 and still only 3x so it's
going to be very interesting to do the
unbiased camera comparison those videos
are always a ton of fun we get so many
awesome comments from you guys so
definitely subscribe so you don't miss
out on that and now let's answer that
original question well honestly for only
two hundred dollars more the iPhone just
gives you so much the display quality is
so much better the speakers the
performance the battery life differences
now yes the pixel 7 Pro destroyed the 14
plus but the pro Max just takes it to a
whole new level where the 200 is way
worth it if you're willing to go with
iOS which many people are so if you can
spend the extra money then I would
definitely do it for this iPhone so
hopefully you guys enjoy enjoyed this
video and if you disagree with me let me
know in the comment section below but if
you enjoyed it click that Circle above
to check out more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]